Let's
go.
the wine of Babylon.
Now, the Bible talks a lot about
Babylon, and we've been dealing with
this issue in the last few lectures. And
last night we did Revelation chapter 13
and we looked at the various components
of the first beast, the one that rises
out of the sea. And we saw that it
speaks with a mouth of a
>> lion. It has a lion's mouth. And the
lion was the symbol of
>> Babylon. Now, the Bible also warns
that God's people are in Babylon and
that at some stage God says, "Come out
of her, my people." Is that right?
Now, what good would it be if God said
to you, "Come out of Babylon," and you
have no idea what Babylon is. Wouldn't
that be a problem? Because what would
you come out of? You wouldn't know what
to come out of.
So the Bible has to actually define
Babylon for us so that we may know what
it is we have to come out of. And we've
looked at a couple of pointers already.
We've identified some of the components
of Babylon already. And one of the main
components, the one counterfeating the
son of god who is in the place of the
son of god because Babylon babortal
to
knowledge, wisdom, god and the wordon
also means confusion as a whole word. So
this word tells us that there is another
way to salvation besides through Jesus
Christ.
And the beast that we referred to the
little horn power forms a very large
component. It is the false Christ the
one who is in the place of antichristtos
of Jesus Christ.
So if this is the power that will be
followed by the whole world and last
night we also saw that how much of the
world wondered after the beast
or was astounded after about the beast?
It was all the world. So how prominent
is this power and what does it
represent? Why does God condemn it in
the strongest terms?
I'll tell you why. Because it is a
counterfeit system. And a counterfeit
system tries to sell itself as the real
thing when in actual fact it is false.
The Bible says have nothing to do with
the evil works of darkness, but rather
expose them. Expose them. Ephesians. So
let's have a look at why
the system is called Babylon. And what
is the prominent role that the beast
power which we have sadly identified as
the papacy plays in this Babylonian
trinity.
We have also a more sure word of
prophecy where unto you do well to take
heed as unto a light that shineth in a
dark place until the day dawn and the
day star arise in your hearts. Second
Peter 1:19. We have to diligently study
the prophecies. We have to know what's
going on behind the scenes. We have to
know why and wherefore God says things.
Jeremiah 516 and 7 speaking about
literal Babylon says, "Flee out of the
midst of Babylon and deliver every man
his soul."
Now, the type literal Babylon is our
lesson book to tell us why God calls the
endtime conferency
also Babylon.
be not cut off in her iniquity,
for this is the time of the Lord's
vengeance. He will render unto her a
recompense." So, this system is a
deceiving system. It has a false
religion and leads people to pition.
Babylon has been a golden cup in the
Lord's hand that made all the earth
drunken. The nations have drunken her
wine. And therefore the nations are mad.
In other words, the nations that drink
the wine of Babylon, they go crazy.
Wine in the Bible. Now, if Jesus is the
vine, then the wine that comes forth
from the vine must be what he says, must
be his fruit, must be the doctrines. So,
Babylon has false doctrines. Now, we're
not going to deal with all the false
doctrines tonight. We're going to look
at why the Bible defines the system as
Babylon. And we're going to go to
ancient Babylon in order to do that.
That is why it is called Babel because
the Lord confused the language of the
whole world. Genesis 11:7-9.
This has been a thorn in the devil's
side ever since that time when they were
building the tower of babel in order to
unite in apostasy towards God because
God had said he will never destroy the
world by a flood again. They still built
a tower in case he tried something like
that in the future. So God separated the
nations and that is something that was
essential for our salvation because by
separating the nations this constant
tension on this planet would lead people
to seek God because if you are
threatened by one or the other you seek
God and God can stay in the minds of
men. The devil doesn't like the
separation and he wants one unitary
system whereby all will worship him.
And there followed another angel saying
this is now the book Revelation Babylon
is fallen is fallen that great city
because she made all the nations drink
of the wine of the wroth of her
fornication. Revelation 14:8. So in
other words, here you have a system
that is selling wine that is full of
fornication. That is apostasy towards
God. Now if you are apostasizing towards
God, who are you serving?
>> The other one. The other one. And he
also has a gob. He also has a gob. He
presents himself either in this form or
in that form or whatever form he wants
to present himself. But whatever form it
is, it's not God's way, it's his way. So
here is a false system that has been set
up. Now, Revelation 16:19 tells us and
the great city referring to spiritual
Babylon. It cannot be ancient Babylon
because God said ancient Babylon would
never be rebuilt. So that serves as a
type and a type by definition is always
smaller than the antitype. The lamb
stands for Jesus Christ. So the lamb is
just a small example of the greater more
prominent antitype which is Christ
himself. Babylon the type stands for
those who would apostasize against God.
And in a larger on a larger scale at the
end of time it represents all those who
in confederacy
work together to oppose God.
Jerusalem
served as a type as all of those who
would seek God and seek salvation
through the lamb. So that's typology. So
here we have this great city was divided
into three parts. So now we know Babylon
has three components and we're going to
deal with all three of them in this
lecture series. Don't miss any of this.
And the cities of the nations fell and
all the great Babylon came into the
remembrance before God to give unto her
the cup of the wine of the fierceness of
his wroth. So if you stay in Babylon,
then you're going to have to deal with
this side of the issue. God will
recompense.
And I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs. This is heavy. The spirit that
actuates Babylon
consists of unclean spirits. And they
came out of the mouth of the dragon.
That's Satan himself because the Bible
defines the dragon as Satan in
Revelation 12. And out of the mouth of
the beast.
Revelation tells us about the beast. And
we've already dealt with it in great
detail. the little horn power of Daniel
chapter 7 and the beast out of the sea.
Revelation chapter 13 and we sadly had
to identify it as the papacy and out of
the mouth of the false prophet. You know
in the other languages this comes out a
little bit better. If you take it in the
German then it is
fet if you know what that means. There's
a harsher word and a softer word for the
word mouth and the dragon and the beast
get the harsh harsher word and the false
prophet gets the sadder mouth. Now, the
false prophet
are all those who once had the truth but
return back to the mother system. For
they are the spirits of devils working
miracles. And we looked at miracles last
night. And these miracles will deceive
people which go forth unto the kings of
the earth. That's the political systems
of the world. Of how much of the world?
the whole world to gather them to the
battle of the great day of God Almighty.
So the conflict is going to be between
this false trinity
and the people of God. Those who keep
the commandments of God and hold to the
testimony of Jesus. So mystic Babylon
consists of the dragon component,
the dragon, Satan working directly with
man. That would be spiritism, strange
occurrences, appearances,
uh all of those spiritualistic
activities, the beast, organized
religion culminating in the papacy, and
the false prophet, those who once knew
but are returning to false prophecies.
We are told byius that Constantine in
order to recommend the new religion to
the heathen transferred into it the
outward ornaments to which they had been
accustomed in their own development of
Christian doctrine. And the evidence
points out the fact that Christianity
early on
was paganized and just took on the garb
of Christianity. And this is derived
according to the writings of the secret
societies. It can be traced all the way
back to Simon Magus.
Simon Magus followed Peter and Paul to
Rome. And he was a magician.
He was a pagan priest who put on a cloak
of Christianity because he wanted to
have that power. And Peter rebuked him.
And this Simon Magus, by the way, the
name Simon also means Peter. He followed
them to Rome. And this occult mixture
between paganism and Christianity finds
its seat in him. He was the Petra PTR.
And the Petra Peters have nothing to do
with Simon Peter the apostle, but have
to do with Simon Magus.
I know that after I leave, savage wolves
will come in amongst you and will not
spare the flock. Even from your own
number, men will arise and distort the
truth in order to draw away disciples
after them. The teachings of Magus of
Simon Magus having come from Sumeriia
were cababalistic in nature and out of
cabalism comes.
And nasticism is the teaching that the
messiah is the Osiris of old. So the
ancient Egyptian mythologies which come
from the book of the dead which come
from Tat Moses III who was the very
pharaoh who clashed with Moses who was
the high priest of occultism and
paganism.
this religion of Osiris and Isis the
goddess. This how shall we say this
anthropomorphic
human input into this religion and
androgenic worship because the deities
were both male and female and they were
interchangeable.
This religion is what was brought into
Christianity.
Now the ancient gods if we want to find
the thread into modern Babylon we'll
have to look at ancient Babylon the
calaldanss worship bell or meadok and
then there was n the son and the son was
also worshiped as tamuz
and the women of Israel were very apt to
weep for tamuz because he was a
artificial a counterfeit
Messiah. The devil had the Messiah
prepared before the real one so that
people would not accept the real one.
How do we know Jesus is the real one? Do
you remember the prophecy we dealt with?
Do you remember the prophecy on the
Messiah, the 70we pro prophecy where the
rabbitic curse says that you are cursed,
your hand, your your finger, your wrist,
your arm, that you are cursed if you
should number the 70 weeks because it
identifies
the real Messiah spot on.
So the counterfeit Messiah was already
there and he was Tamuz. Then there was
the goddess Ria. She was also worshiped
as ishta from which we have the word
Easter today aarta beltus and she was
the queen of heaven. She was the queen
of heaven and she was known as the wroth
subduer. Now in Catholicism we have
exactly the same thing. It is stated
nobody comes to the father except
through Jesus but nobody comes to Jesus
except through Mary. And Mary is the
mediatric. She is the wroth subduer. So
we have a similar system to what we had
here in Babylonian times. Now if you
take these religions and you look at
them on a worldwide basis in Egypt,
these deities were worshiped as Isis the
goddess and her son Osiris. And Osiris
was the one who died
became part of the son was resurrected
and came back to this earth as Horus.
Horus the divine child and the divine
mother Isis. So you have mother and
child worship. In India they were
worshiped as is and is. It's the same
religion. In fact the Babylonian
religion is today the universal religion
of all the religious systems. China it
was Shing Mu and the holy mother and
son. In Greece, Cirrus and Irene and
Plutus. In Rome, it was Futuna and
Jupiter Pure. This was the ancient
system of worship. It's interesting that
in the latest seminar taking place about
Christianity in the world today, the
so-called Jesus seminar,
where they are speaking about a new
reformation.
God forbid that we should call it a
>> Amen. where they talk about a
reformation and want to put Jesus on a
par with Osiris. I have a problem with
that.
>> Amen.
>> Because the one is a counterfeit of the
other and the religious doctrines
associated with the book of the dead
which concerns Osiris is totally the
opposite of what the Bible says.
Well, Ezekiel 8:16 says that the door of
the temple of the Lord between the porch
and the altar were about five and 20 men
with their backs towards the temple of
the Lord and their faces towards the
east and they worship the sun towards
the east. So ancient Israel although
they knew God and knew the power of God
were already diverted towards this
paganism. I'll tell you why. Because
it's a very sophisticated religion.
Don't underestimate paganism. We think
these peoples were were silly or stupid
because they worship pagan gods. We're
no less stupid. Did you know that? Most
of my life I served pagan gods. Didn't
even know it. Didn't even know it. But
that's a fact.
So they worshiped the sun because sun
worship is a perfect counterfeit
of messianic worship. So in other words,
it's easy to substitute the one for the
other. Put him in the right garb and
apply the right liturgy and you've got a
religion. Now the religion comes from
the legend of Nimrod and Semiramis.
Nimrod was a warrior against the Lord
and he was the one who apostized
and then he was put to death and his
widow Semi Ramos claimed that he had
been resurrected or had take been taken
up to the sun and had been reborn
through her. And as
the fish swims in the waters of the
Euphrates,
so the fish symbol became the symbol of
the god that protected Nimrod in this
transition.
And then she gave birth to the child who
was of course the birth, the rebirth,
the resurrection if you like in a child
of Osiris. In Scandinavia they were
worshiped as Friger and Balder, Venus
and Adonis in Rome and Ashttoret and Bal
in Phoenicia. And the child became the
sinbearer and became the savior. And
this was his name. He was called
Zoroast. By the way, Zoroastism is alive
and well and living in the Middle East.
It is the seed of the woman mitas the
savior. Mitraism is one of the most
sophisticated forms of sun worship. And
we will be dealing with mitraism because
it is astounding who mitra was and what
mitraism is today. Even here in the
United States, you'll be surprised how
much mitraism there is.
Dionius is the sinbearer. Bakus the
branch. Vishna the victim man. Osiris
king and kings. Do you recognize those
titles?
Those are all titles that belong to
Jesus Christ and they have been captured
by these pagan deities.
Now if you were a priest of the pagan
deities
then you worship this deity in many many
forms. One of the most prominent forms
was in the form of the god dug on. And
the priests to dug on dug on. On is the
Egyptian for god. Dug is fish. So it's
the fish form of this god. The priests
wore the fish miter on the head and uh
they had a complete fish cloak. And the
fish in ancient Egypt and in pagan
religions becomes the symbol of Dagon.
In this particular Egyptian one, you
have the horns of the bull. The bull,
the first letter of the Hebrew alphabet
was the symbol of the bull. In in the
east, it was the alpha, the alf, the
elephant, the elephant becomes the bull
of the east. And these creatures become
symbols of the sun god. Therefore, you
have bull worship and you have elephant
worship. And the horns that were between
the eyes of the bull also are are a
symbol of the half moon, the sickle
moon, which becomes a symbol of the womb
of the woman which receives the rebirth
of the sun god.
So later on they became a little bit
more sophisticated and the priests of
Daron wore the fish miter and the cloak.
And then later on they substituted the
fishcloak for colorful robes normally in
the colors crimson which is the color of
sacrifice, purple which is the color of
royalty.
Now do you recognize that sort of miter
on the top there? Do people wear it
today in another form? Yes, they do.
Well, let's go and see if we can find it
really in the ancient Babylonian
um finds. Yes, we can. This one here
comes from the Pergamo Museum. I took
this one myself. There you have the
symbol of the sun. And the wavy lines,
by the way, wavy lines emanating from
the sun are the sign of the female
symbol. Straight lines are the sign of
the male symbol. Through the union of
the male and female deity, you had the
birth of the savior. And uh here you
have priests of Dagon walking around
with pales over there containing holy
water. And they would have little
brushes which were made from hissop and
then they would sprinkle the people to
wash them. Is that a ritual that is
practiced today? Yes, very much so.
Here you have a priest, a high priest of
Dagon. There you had the symbol in the
sky of the god Shamash, who is the
symbol of the deity. He has the wings,
normally the wings of an eagle. And then
you have the solar symbol in the middle.
There's another solar symbol which is
two stars superimposed over each other
making eight spokes. So you make a solar
wheel of eight spokes and if you were
the high priest then you had to bow down
to the high priest or if you were the
representative or the god himself and
you had to often kiss the ring and kiss
the slipper.
Now if we go to Rome, this is the
pantheon outside Rome and this is the
place where all the deities of ancient
times were worshiped. And outside you
have this little statue over here where
you have a cuboid down there which is
also a symbol of paganism by the way.
Then you have the alf standing at the
bottom symbol of the sun god. Then you
have the Stella which is the symbol of
the phallic symbol of Osiris because
when Isis put him back together again,
this is one of the parts she had to
reconstruct.
And on top of that, you have the symbol
of the cross and we'll deal with that a
little bit later. If you go into the
pantheon, you have interesting little
things on the floor. You have squares.
The pagan deities were either in a
square or they were represented in a
circle. So you have circles and you have
squares. And because they were both good
and evil representing both shades,
therefore you had black and white
squares.
Now if we go to Roman Catholic churches,
you will find and cathedrals, you'll
find the fish over there. This is the
the ancient goddess Aarta. There's the
fish miter with the symbol of the star
or the sun and the half moon over there.
And then you have a whole plethora of
pagan symbols in the hand. Many of which
are used today. This one is used by the
medical world. That one up there is very
interesting. Here's a fish, for example.
This comes out of Hinduism as a symbol
of the pagan deity. There was the god
Cyrus. And here you have some
interesting symbols on the miter of the
pope. There you have the symbol of the
sun god. That's the one of the main
symbols of the sun deity where the four
and the four sprokes within a circle.
And that over there
is a cross which is known as the Maltes
cross. And the knights of Malta wear
that particular cross. And we will see
that that particular cross, look at it
carefully, is a direct symbol of the sun
deity. It's got nothing to do with
Christianity. Well, let's go there. Here
is one of the kings of um ancient times.
And this is a an Assyrian king, Sardon.
What has he got around his neck? Can you
see it?
This is in the British Museum. There you
have the Maltese cross which is the same
cross that the pope has on his side and
he's pointing here with his finger like
this which is also a symbol of the one
meaning the one deity the number one the
one stands for the sun god there you
have the symbol which we just saw on the
miter of the pope symbol of the sun god
there's another symbol you have the
compass the set square and the compass
which you find in freemasonry
Over there you have the half moon with a
sickle in it which you find in many
religions. There you have the
multi-layered one as you find in the
Aztec religions of sun worship. And
there you have the triple miter, the
three aspects of the sun god. Those are
the some of the main symbols of sun
worship as you find them in ancient
times. Where do you think we'll find
them most prominently today?
Probably in the papacy. Well, all of
these are wearing fish miters. Those are
miters of Dagon. Let's go to Basilica S.
Clement, one of the churches in Rome.
Let's go down to the bottom. You will
find that they used an altar which on
the one side was inscribed with
Christianized symbols and on the other
had petroglyphs of pagan sun worship. So
both religions worshiped in the same
capacity, used the same venue, switched
the altars and eventually they fused
into one. Church history tells us
Christianity became the established
religion of the Roman Empire and took
the place of paganism.
Christianity as it existed in the dark
ages might be termed baptized paganism.
It's very interesting. Let's see what uh
what the Roman Catholic Church has to
say about this. The story of American
Catholicism, page 37. It has often been
charged that Catholicism is overlaid
with many pagan incrustations.
Catholicism is ready to accept that
accusation and even to make it her
boast. The great God Pan
is not really dead. He's baptized.
Aha.
So paganism is within the church and the
real deity behind the scenes that is
worshiped is not Jesus Christ but is
Osiris in whatever form he is in the
form of pan. You would find him in the
groves. He was the god of the groves. He
was the god of fear. That's where the
word panic comes from. And this god Pan
is the one that is worshiped either as a
beautiful young man who wears and
carries the sheep as the shepherd or he
is worshiped as the one with the goat's
feet depending which aspect you are
looking at because whether you worship
him in his positive sense or whether you
worship him in his negative sense it's
the same deity it's the same whether you
worship Lucifer or whether you worship
ship. The good side, the dark and the
light are one and the same deity. Well,
let me take you to this very prominent
Roman Catholic cathedral.
And uh I was looking for these symbols
in this Roman Catholic cathedral in the
south of Germany. And here I found what
they call the statue of David. Can you
see it over there with the sheep
carrying the sheep around his neck? And
I was wondering whether that was a
representation of David or whether it
was a representation of the other one.
Well, it's not too difficult to tell
because what has he got in his hand?
>> He's carrying the pan flute. Now, did
David ever play the pan flute? Yes or
no?
>> No. David didn't carry the pan flute. He
had the hop, the hand hop. So this
instrument tells me that this is pan and
not the other one. Then I was interested
having seen Pan over here whether I
would find Pan in his negative form in
the same construction in the same
building. And sure enough there he is.
There's Pan with the goat's feet and all
the other symbols of paganism including
Yianus the two-headed one. So this is
paganism in its highest form. If we go
to St. John's Lateran which is the
church where the papacy speaks excided
or if you go to St. Peter's the whole
system over here the whole construction
is a system of pagan sun worship the
site is the ancient site by the way most
of the cathedrals in the world are built
on the very ancient pagan sites where
the ancient deities were worshiped. The
construction of these buildings are also
in in accordance with the ancient pagan
rights. So here you have the triangle
for example you have the famous sun dome
and you have this pillared structure
which is normally known as the seat of
the goddess.
And if you enter into this place on the
floor you will find the official title
of the papacy which is Pontifex Maximos.
Now this title comes all the way from
Babylon. It has been changed through
time. When Meido Persia took over, the
Meo Persians took over the religion, the
same religious system, the priests of
Babylon revolted at some stage were
driven out and fled to Pergamos. And
there the Pontix king Pontifix Maximos
resided until Roman times when he gave
his title, his vestments and all the
powers of being a deity as well as a
high priest to the emperor and that's
why Roman emperors got the title
Pontifix Maximus. And when Rome declined
and the seat of the Caesar was empty,
the bishop of Rome claimed the title
Pontifffects Maximus, which means the
bridge builder. He's the bridge between
heaven and earth. So he takes the place
of Jesus Christ who is the bridge
between heaven and earth. And if we want
to see whether we find any of the
interesting symbols, this is on the
floor of the Vatican. What do we have
over there? There we have the triple
crown. Where did we see that? It's a
symbol of the ancient religion that we
saw there associated with the Babylonian
system and the Assyrian kings. Here you
have another interesting symbol. That's
the lion with eagle's wings. What does
the Bible define that as?
>> Defines that as Babylon. Then you have
the flu dei which is the symbol of the
union of the male and the female
deities. And then you have the split
tail which is the symbol of Dagon. You
have them all right over there. You even
have the pagan seat, which they claim is
Peter's seat.
Now, in order to qualify for salvation,
you have to enter in through the door.
Notice how this is all based on the
truth because the devil is
counterfeating the truth. Christ says,
"I am the
door. Nobody comes to the father except
through me." In paganism, there are
three doors. a large one, smaller one,
and a medium one, a baby one. The one
standing for the male deity, the female
deity, and the child deity. So, you have
father, mother, son, if you like. Well,
here you have uh that in the ancient
Bolivian culture, that was a typical sun
door. There's the symbol of the sun god
at the top. And here you have the three
holy stones or rocks in the futimagaru
seashore that is in Japan. And the one
would be the father, the mother and the
son. And on top of it you also have the
portal uh of the divine couple the door
the sun door leading inside. Also in
Fatimugaru you have the bronze frogs
which were also a form of the deity
because it's a form of pantheism. God is
in everything. And you also had the
frogs of course in Egypt. So these
religions are not dead. They're alive
and well. Here you have the winged sun
of Sang the Dar Mosque in the Hindu
system. So Hinduism, the ancient
religions, the Eastern religions, they
all have the suns of Babylon. Now, who
would you expect if he was going to
become the high priest of Babylon in our
time to be associated with Sundors
today?
Wouldn't you expect the papacy, if the
Bible is correct, to have the same
thing? Well, there you have it. Jubilee,
John Paul 2 blesses the holy door on New
Year's Day. Where in the Bible do you
read about a holy door?
Do you read about it there anyway? Jesus
says, "I am the door. I am the way. Come
through me. But here you use this symbol
in a totally different sense. By the
way, every single pagan incrustation
that you can possibly think of is right
here on this outfit that he is wearing.
Well, the papacy also claims that he has
the keys and he calls them the keys of
Peter. They are the Petra keys because
there they are in Babylon where the lion
god the keys to heaven and to hell. Do
you remember that he said that the
sentence of the priest is preeminent and
that God has to subscribe to it. So it
is the system that determines whether
you go to heaven or whether you are lost
and not God.
Now there you have another symbol of the
lion god over there in ancient times. So
the keys are a symbol of the lion.
Interesting staff that this lion god is
wearing or carrying. All these ancient
deities and the high priests of these
deities carried such staffs with a pine
cone on the top because the pine cone is
a symbol of fertility. So now if we go
into the rituals of how they treated the
high priest who was a reincarnation
just like the pharaoh of Osiris and
therefore a representative of Osiris in
the form of Horus if you like on this
earth in the ancient cultures they were
carried normally in a stool like this
and associated with it you had fans
which consisted of feathers. They could
be peacock feathers and the eye on the
peacock feather is the eye of the all
wise one of the deity they worship or it
could be ostrich feathers because the
feather is associated with the bird
which in the final analysis leads us
back to the phoenix but we'll come to
that a little bit later. Now there's the
papacy and here you have Pope Pas still
being carried around in this very
fashion exactly like in pagan times with
exactly the same rituals with the twin
keys which come from Babylon. The hand
signals that are being used here are
very interesting because they are all
pagan sun worship systems. If you take
the the dancers of the Hindus, the hand
signals they use, everyone is
meticulously practiced because it has a
meaning in terms of sun worship. Now
there's the triple crown which you would
find stems from paganism with which the
papacy
is installed or the pope is crowned.
Here the crown is being brought. There
are the twin uh tails at the back.
Cardinals lying down while this takes
place.
We have a musical interlude. That's
nice.
Here you can see the ordination of new
bishops and cardinals. Look at them
lying down exactly as it was in pagan
times. Here you have a triple tiara of
the pagan god 1800 BC. Note the triple
crown 1 2 3 and there you have the horn
tiara of the Assyrian winged god. There
you have the triple crown in Krishna
which is Hinduism. So the triple crown
is a symbol of the ancient religion of
Babylon. And there you have the winged
bull cherub also with the triple crown
stemming from Assyrian times, Babylonian
times. So the one who wears the triple
crown now is the high priest of the
ancient deities.
Here's the tiara of Pope 6us. There are
six serpents beneath the occult pyramid
on this one.
Now let's look at mother and child
worship.
Mary and the child Jesus.
This symbol is exactly the same as you
have in paganism. And it's interesting
that you have black Madonas and you have
white Madonas. You have black
Jesus and a white Jesus. Now in paganism
it was exactly the same. Osiris was
either worshiped as black or he was
worshiped as white depending on what
aspect of the deity you favored. In the
game of chess, what do you have there?
>> Black and white.
>> You have black and white squares. And
the game of chess is designed, it's an
old ancient occult game designed through
Freemasonry to show that the pawn, even
the pawn can overthrow the king and
outmaneuver him. In fact, you can
exchange the king for the female form of
the deity and become the queen if you
like. So, black and white was a symbol
that was already present in Osiris
worship and in Isis worship and you have
it in Catholicism as well. You have the
black Madonna and you have the white
Madonna. If you go to Eastern culture,
you have exactly the same mother and
child worship. Ei and Isizara, Shingmu
and the Holy Child. There you have it in
in Egypt, Isis and Osiris or the birth
of Horus. There you have it in the
Hittite culture, mother and child
worship. Of course, mother and child
will become prominent in Roman
Catholicism. But if you want to make
people believe that it stands for
something else, you change the name of
the deities. It's no problem. They've
been changing throughout history. The
Greeks didn't have the same names as the
Meo Persians. They didn't have the same
names as the Egyptians. They didn't have
the same names as the Babylonians. But
it was one in the same deity because the
attributes, the character was identical.
So all these deities here you have them
in the ancient Aztec religion quetel
cotle and the the child and sometimes
you had them as male and female black
white interchangeable all the phases the
androgenic system that the deity is both
male and female black madonas in the
Roman Catholic Church and and black
messiahs very common
and white madas and white children. Here
you have it in uh Hinduism. This comes
from the British Museum. There you have
the mother and there you have the holy
child, the one who will be the savior.
This is paganism. This has nothing to do
with Christianity because Jesus says
there is one mediator between man and
God. And who is that?
>> The man Christ Jesus. You don't have
another mediator. There is no Mary to
take a place or any other saint or
anyone who can act as mediator. This is
paganism.
But it's not Christianity.
This is Isis in her spiritualistic form.
This is how she appears in new age
rituals and manifestations. We'll be
dealing with that in another lecture.
And here you have the symbols, the
ancient pagan symbols of Hermes and Isis
right here with the six-pointed star in
the middle of the circle or the
fiveointed stars in other places are
also used. This symbol, where do you
think I found this? This symbol of the
ancient gods.
I found this in the Jesuit cathedral in
the south of Europe in southern Germany.
What is that doing there? Or what are
these symbols of sun worship doing in
Czechova in uh Czechoslovakia or in
Poland all over the world? Well, let's
have a look at what the new ens Catholic
encyclopedia says. Pas 12th affirmed
strongly the queenship of Mary. So now
you have a queen in heaven, but Beltus
was called the queen in heaven.
inserting in the calendar for May 31 a
new feast of Mary Queen. So Mary is
remodeled and reshaped to fit into the
shoes of the ancient deity and placed in
front of the people as the new mediator.
That's pretty sad because Jesus is taken
out of the equation. Pas 12th
consecrated the world to the immaculate
heart of Mary. So this is not
consecration to Christ. I'm not knocking
Mary. Mary was a was a blessed woman.
She was a good woman. But her heritage
is being misused here. And she was
revered then as mother and queen October
31, 1942 as a public recognition of her
queenship. It's amazing that the ancient
full complete system of Babylonian
worship only really came to full
fruition in our time.
Now let's have a look at some of these
fascinating portrayals of transference
of the mediatorial road from Jesus to
Mary. This one I found at Gapichi in
Rome. Here you have Jesus placing the
crown of thorns on Mary's head and she
has the wounds in her hands.
So Mary is the one that becomes the
mediator, the one who suffered and died.
And it is claimed that through Mary we
are saved because Mary is the one who
through her obedience redeemed us
whereas Eve failed. Now remember I was
Catholic myself. I was a staunch
Catholic for many many years. So I was
just as stunned as you are probably
tonight.
Now this ancient goddess,
she was part of a fertility right and
people would pray to her for fertility
and for nurturing. So does Mary fulfill
the same role? Absolutely.
Let's go to the muk grotto lag grotto
dle in
Bethlehem very close to the church of
the nativity and let me take you down
there into the milk grotto here you have
a symbol it's in the church I know it
looks a bit funny and I apologize but uh
this is the picture that they use as an
icon Mary with her breast out symbol of
fertility where she feeds this child And
people come to this grotto in their
hordes to pray for fertility problems.
Now, if you look on the ceilings of the
cave, you find these white splotches.
And it's called the milk grotto because
it states that these white splotches
that you find over here are the milk of
Mary because when she fed the baby
Jesus, her milk squirted against the
walls of the of the cave and made those
white splotches.
This is what it says there and this has
been authenticated by the papacy and
there is a a testimony from the Vatican
that this is an authentic miracle
situation.
Now I asked the the the guide there who
happened to be also the cantor of the
church of the nativity that's the one
the big one where all the trouble is in
Israel now the cantor himself I asked
him excuse me I'm just a little bit
curious these white splotches that we
see against the walls I've seen them in
all the other caves as well
are they also the milk of Mary oh no No,
those are natural. But these come from
the milk of Mary. You see? Now, this
might sound a bit ridiculous, but I'm
just showing you that the same fertility
cult surrounding this ancient deity is
also ascribed to Mary. And actually,
when you think about it, it's quite
sick. Now, if she's queen in heaven,
that means she is the goddess of heaven.
Now, Mary, the queen of heaven, here you
have a Catholic picture where angels are
crowning Mary as queen.
Here you have on an entrance in another
cathedral in Europe, you have Mary being
crowned by the father and the son as
queen of heaven. While the worshippers
at the bottom are not worshiping either
the f father nor or the son, but their
homage is towards Mary.
Here's another one with Jesus looking on
giving his sanction while the archangels
are crowning Mary.
Here you have another crowning of father
and son. Crowning Mary direct. So now
it's not an angel, it's father and son
direct. And here you have the pope
praying in front of a statue of Mary.
And here you have him crowning Mary. So
you have the whole ritual. You have the
whole system of paganism built in over
here to make Mary beltus the queen of
heaven, the wroth subduer, the one who
stands in the place of the real
mediator. So if you have this picture
over here, you have the Holy Spirit in
the above there. You have Mary in the
center. And if you look at the disciples
eyes, where are they directed? Up there
or to Mary? To Mary. So she has become
the mediator. Now do we find the symbol
in ancient times? Absolutely. This
female deity was also worshiped as the
dove.
And there you have the double dove,
which was also a symbol, two-headed one,
which can later also be interpreted as a
a two-headed fernx or a two-headed
eagle. Uh, which is an interesting
symbol of Freemasonry, by the way. And
here you have the symbol of, you know,
the dove. Here you have this symbol of,
you know, which is a symbol used by the
United Nations for peace. Here is
another one of the dove. Symbol of you.
And the dove represents the gentler
force and takes the place of the holy
spirit. So the female deity is also the
one that is the one who emanates as the
gentle one, the holy spirit. So when you
find over many many uh preaching rosters
you find this symbol you're not always
sure is it a reference to the Holy
Spirit or is it actually a reference to
you know and when you find it in the
solar blaze is that what Christianity is
all about Ezekiel 8:13 and 14 turn ye
that again and thou shalt see greater
abominations that they do. Then he
brought me to the door of the gate of
the Lord's house which was towards the
north
and behold there sat women weeping for
tamuz. So ancient Israel was duped into
worshiping the mother and the child
and modern Israel is being duped talking
about spiritual Israel to do the same.
The interesting thing about these
ancient gods is that they were al always
associated with dark places. They were
associated with the groves. The goddess
Diana, she was the goddess of hunting
and uh very often a deer or something
like that was associated with her as
well. And she also in all the pagan
cultures emanated out of the cave. She
came out of the cave. So here you have
in these uh depictions over here you
have these statues inside caves. Now
these are in the cathedrals. This one is
in the main Jesuit cathedral in um
Czechoslovakia.
And there you have these deities or
statues of them within caves. And you
have the letters I HS above which today
they tell you means in his service. But
of course it doesn't mean in his service
at all. The Catholic Church says it
refers to ESOS homminum salv which means
Jesus the savior of men. But if you
belong to an occult circle, you will
recognize it as Isis Horus Seb, the
Egyptian trinity. Isis, Horus, Seb. Seb
was the dark one. He is the other side
of Osiris. Osiris and Seb are really
interchangeable. The one is the light
and the other one is the darkness. The
one is good, the other one is evil. If
you would like, you could worship them
today. In occult circles, they do. They
worship them as Lucifer the lightbearer
or as Satan. Satanism and Luciferian
worship worship one in the same deity.
And that is why Luciferians and
Satanists are often good buddies.
The one practicing the light, the other
one practicing the darkness. Satanists
have to do good deeds in order to
appease their god. And they have to
sacrifice to their god. Luciferians have
to do exactly the same thing. And they
can interchange. They can sit on both
chairs because it doesn't matter whether
you worship on the dark side or whether
you worship on the light side. And it
gets frightening
because you cannot tell the two apart
sometimes.
Well, if you go to the ancient
cathedrals, this is uh the cathedrals in
Cologne. You have the symbol of Apollo,
the sun god there. And then you have the
moon and the stars. Sun, moon and stars.
That's the three aspects of the sun god.
Like you had Brahma, sa, Vishnu. Brahma
the sun rising. Sa the sun at the
meridian. Vishnu the victim man. The sun
plunges into the waters at night,
becomes Dagon, the fish god or Poseidon
rises out of the water and is worshiped
either as Poseidon or the serpent or the
or the um triune form
in this cathedral over here. You have
very interesting relief here. You have
the lion with eagle's wings with the sun
at the back. A very prominent Babylonian
symbol. And uh the Roman Catholic Church
calls this a symbol of St. Mark. Now,
I'm sure you'll find great difficulty
finding a lion with eagle's wings with a
solar blaze behind the head as a symbol
of St. Mark. Would you?
Now, what is he looking at? He's looking
at a circle over here with a cross in
it. And that was one of the main symbols
of the solar deity. This was a symbol of
Lucifer. the symbol of the circle with a
cross in it. You find it in many many
organizations
today. The other symbol of course is the
symbol of the bull. Remember the bull is
the number one letter. The one the
symbol of of the lightbearer Lucifer
also with the blaze behind him. They
call him St. Luke of Marcos or Luke. And
there you have again the same symbol
also butterflies
symbol of fertility cult. The butterfly
goes from flower to flower. The bee is
also a symbol of the fertility cult. It
also goes from flower to flower to
flower. Young girls, if you have the
butterfly tattooed onto your shoulder,
it has a much deeper meaning than you
might think. Let's see if we can find
the symbols of the bull and the lion.
Sure we can. There they are. The Isis
and Uranus temple number to three.
Encyclopedia of the unexplained magic,
Occultism, and Parasychology.
Isis is associated with both the bull
cult and the lion cult and the Phoenix
cult. There's the Phoenix.
All right, back to Catholicism.
If you go to Roman Catholic gardens
associated with cathedrals or with
monasteries, in the garden you will find
Mary often depicted in a cave situation.
It's the goddess of the grove.
Where do you read something like that in
the Bible? The goddess of the grove and
Mary in the cathedral's basement is also
in the cave and comes out of the cave.
And here you have the occult way of
writing Mary. The M is capitalized over
here. M. The M is the sigma on its side
and it's the symbol that is used by the
occult world. Masonry, Freemasonry
uses the M as well as one of its chief
identifying features. Then you have the
A as a triangle and it's a seximal
triangle 60 60°.
It's a 666 triangle. The dot of the eye
is superimposed on top and the dot
becomes the symbol of the sun. It also
has another connotation which is
somewhat naughty which we will leave
out. And then you're left with Ria who
was the ancient goddess of the east. So
here you have her in her full glory
coming out of the cave. And interesting
what you will also find in paganism is
three arches as you can see it over
there. Now I've already shown you three
arches in ancient temples when we went
to Petra. Remember we went to the one
temple and I showed you three arches and
I said that has to do with paganism. Now
in Catholicism you find three arches
associated with the deities and the
goddess or the gods often come out of
the cave. That's why at Lords you have
the pope praying in the grotto. Now this
is not something that is just for
um Catholicism. It's all the pagan
religions. The goddess Diana, she was
the god of the forests and then she was
also the god the goddess of hunting.
So that is what you have. Now here in
Japan you have another interesting
feast. This is the sun goddess Amiter
Razo as she emerges emerges out of the
cave in their annual festivals they
celebrate this goddess. Notice that her
face is painted white and her hands are
often painted white. Now when you have
mimming for example you have the people
with their hands fa painted white and
their their faces painted white. These
are ancient rituals that can be taken
back to sun worship and we bring them
right into our churches these days as
something unique and exciting. And in a
final analysis, it's sun worship. If you
take the the African culture, when they
become initiated into the fertility of
manhood, the fertility cult, then they
paint their faces white with kaoline
clay and their hands. So this is where
it comes from. So these ancient
goddesses were all the goddesses of the
caves and she's the one who crushes the
serpent's head. But Christ is the one
who should crush the serpent's head. But
the the irony is that she doesn't only
crush the serpent's head, she nurtures
the serpent because the serpent through
her represents death and resurrection.
It is the counterfeit of the death and
the resurrection of Christ. So through
the female you have the fertility power
to produce new life and therefore it has
very heavy sexual connotations. this
religion. Do we find the same in
Catholicism? Yes. Unfortunately,
because Catholicism today is the
ultimate form of the ancient Babylonian
religion and therefore sadly the papacy
must be the high priest of the ancient
occult pagan religion. There you have
Mary
dressed in blue and white. And there you
have her standing on the serpent just
like the ancient goddess. And she's
standing in the half moon which is the
symbol of the womb and is the symbol of
the female deity. By the way, the blue
can be the color of obedience. If you
take the sanctuary, then blue is the
color of obedience. But if you take the
dark side of the worship. So in the one
side you have white and blue which is
obedience and righteousness. But if you
turn the deity on its on its other side
then you will have black. You have the
black Madonna and she has blue. Then
blue becomes the color of promiscuity.
Blue is the color of promiscuity and
sexual debauchery. Have you heard of
blue movies
for example? So both sides are worshiped
say of Mary standing on the serpent's
head. And now let's see what Roman
Catholicism says. This one comes from uh
the cathedral in in St. Mary's Cathedral
in Cape Town. And the sinner says here
to the immaculate Mary, the vows of my
baptism, I renounce Satan. And then it
says, in the presence of the heavenly
court, I choose thee this day for my
mother and mistress. I deliver and
consecrate to thee as thy slave my body
and soul my goods both interior and
exterior and even the value of my good
actions past present and future leaving
to thee the entire and full right of
disposing of me and all that belongs to
me without exception according to thy
good pleasure for the greater glory of
God in time and in eternity. Amen.
>> So who then becomes the ultimate deity
in your life? Is it Jesus or is it Mary?
Must be Mary. So you have replaced Jesus
with another deity. Now I was stunned. I
was stunned when I came here in Syria. I
was recently in Syria and I did a tour
of those ancient sites, archaeological
sites. And I came here to a town called
Sadena which is in a totally Islamic
land. And there you have this huge
statue of Mary and you have this huge
statue of the deer. Now the story goes
that the king, an ancient king, was
traveling through here and he saw the
deer and he went hunting the deer and he
left his troops behind and as he pulled
his his bow and his arrow to shoot the
deer, it transformed itself in front of
him into Mary.
And Mary said to him, "You must build me
a monastery in this place." Now, this is
a site of worship not only for
Catholics, but for Muslims as well. This
is interesting because this is where
religions meet. And here, miracles take
place. In this particular monastery,
they have an icon. And this icon was
supposedly drawn by none other than
Luke. It's an icon of Mary with child,
which is a bit weird because Luke didn't
know Jesus as a baby. But besides that,
the icon leaks tears of oil and the oil
stands there and you can take this oil
as something to cleanse you or for holy
purposes. And as someone was walking out
with the oil, they spilt a drop and of
course it changed into the image of
Mary. Now this is the monastery built on
an ancient hill. So immediately I was
suspicious and thought to myself if this
monastery is standing on an ancient hill
then it's an ancient high place and I
should find the evidence of the ancient
pagan worship of the deity in the form
of the ancient arches. So I went walking
all around this monastery and over this
hill and I was so pleased to find it.
But nevertheless, there it is. The
monastery stands on top of the hill.
It's an ancient high place. That is the
cave. It is sealed with a cross where
the ancient worship took place. There
are the triple arches and they have
Greek inscriptions
and they are dedicated to the ancient
pagan deities. So, Catholicism is the
age-old Babylonian
religion
encrusted.
Here is the place where the drop fell
and they have this bar around it with
all these locks on it. I don't know what
purpose the locks serve. They don't lock
anything, but there are lots of them.
Can you see? And there it is. That's
where the drop fell and it formed the
image of Mary. Let me enlarge it for
you. There it is. And this is the
ancient painting that was supposedly
painted by Luke. So you have all these
ancient incrustations and pagan forms of
worship. Now the little baby which is
supposedly Jesus is here worshiped in
this cathedral in Rome as Tamuz.
Now they call him Bambino, baby Jesus.
But look at him crowned in gold and
silver. This is the most precious little
doll that you can imagine. And here are
all the the letters that are written to
Bambino. This is Tamuz. Jesus never came
like that, did he?
>> My Jesus was born in a manger. He didn't
come dressed in gold and jewels and
silver and being worshiped as a little
baby like that. These are the ancient or
the letters that are written.
Catholicism
teaches that you can be forgiven in
advance for your sins even to this day.
Here you have the La Santa Scala and
these are the this is the staircase.
Catholicism claims some amazing stories
to this day. It sounds unbelievable that
this staircase is the one that Jesus
stood on when he was condemned by Pilate
and he had the crown of thorns and the
blood dripped down and there are drops
of blood supposedly still on the
staircase and they've put little plaques
over it. Now you can crawl up that
staircase and if you do this and you
kiss the places where the drops of blood
supposedly fell, then you get 90 days
absolution.
Three months free ahead of time. Go and
have fun. You're forgiven. 3 months
ahead of time. By the way, where that
staircase come from? It was, of course,
in Jerusalem. How did it get here? Well,
Rome claims, and you can find this
today, right there, that it appeared one
night transported by angels from
Jerusalem to Rome. And there it stood
one morning and they built the cathedral
around it. You can believe it if you
like.
Let's have a look at the mass. Well,
this photograph comes from the Church of
All Nations. And you will notice over
here that the altar stands on a rock.
Now in all pagan religions you have holy
stone worship, holy rock worship and God
in the Old Testament constantly warns
against those that have their holy
stones and their holy rocks. Catholicism
is encrusted with it. Catholics teach
that the sacrifice of the mass is and
ought to be considered one and the same
as that of the cross. as the victim is
one and the same namely Christ our Lord.
This is catechism of the council of
tread. This is not just some source. So
Christ is sacrificed again and again
every time the mass is said they crucify
to themselves the son of God aresh and
put him to open shame. Hebrews 6:6. The
Bible says by how many sacrifices did he
make forever? one one
>> one sacrifice forever. So the sacrifice
of the mass is in a sense a symbol of
the victory of Lucifer over Christ. He
keeps him sacrificed and the crucifix
where Christ stays on the crucifix is a
symbol of the victory of Lucifer over
Christ. Now in paganism
the cross was also worshiped as a symbol
of the sun of course and Lucifer made
that one of his main symbols.
Now Hebrews 10:14 says by one offering
one sacrifice he has perfected forever
them that are sanctified. If you look at
the Vatican this comes from the Vatican
museum. You have an angel supporting the
triple crown, supporting Christ on the
cross, keeping him on the cross. So the
crucifix in a sense is a symbol of
victory over Christ. And the eating of
the bread is an ancient pagan ritual.
The eucharist or host has the letters IS
on it. Isis horusip. And the host from
the Latin meaning the sacrifice. The
round wafer whose roundness is so
important in the Roman mystery is
another system of symbol of Bal Babylon
mystery religion ancient and modern page
129. So the roundness is a symbol of the
sun and there you have it in the
evensided cross which is also the symbol
of the sun god the sun deity. All right,
there we have it. In the Assyrian, you
had the symbol of the sun which was
round and it was placed in the half moon
which was the symbol of the birth into
the womb of the sun god and it was
called Bal Hadad
and it was also often a star in a moon
and the star represents the star from
the east. It was called the dog star and
it was a representation of Sirius. Now
remember the ancient Maggi the three
wise men that came to Jesus. Is that
right? Now occultism today in the
Masonic form teaches that the wise men
followed the star in the east and
followed it to Bethlehem. That's what
they teach. Question.
If the wise men came from the east, then
where was the star relative to them over
Bethlehem?
>> It was in the west.
So in actual fact the star that they are
serving is not the star which represents
Jesus Christ but the one in the east
which represents Sirius the dog star and
is a symbol of Lucifer not of Jesus
Christ. So that was the ancient
Mesopotamian symbol of Balhad the star
or the ram disk. It doesn't matter
whether it's the one or the other. The
one is simply the form Horus which is
the rebirth and the other one is the
form Osiris which is the adult form. It
doesn't matter which one it is. So here
you have the symbol of Osiris the round
disc in the half moon which is the
symbol of Isis or there you have the
symbol of Horus which is the the birth
of the sun uh the S O N and the half
moon. Now who uses that symbol today?
Which religion has that as its main
symbol?
Islam Islam has this as its main symbol
and Islam and Catholicism stand side by
side. You go to the to the Middle East.
You go to Islamic countries where
evangelism
is forbidden where you may not proite in
the name of Jesus Christ. You will find
the mosque and the Catholic cathedral
next to each other wherever you go.
Whether you go to Aman, whether you go
to Jerusalem, whether you go to Syria,
you do it and you will see the Roman
Catholic Cathedral and this one standing
side by side. Why?
Because it's the same deity. It's Bal
Hadad. Let's have a look.
Here is the Pope with the wafer,
the roundness representing Bal. Here he
is with a cup. Bakos was the god of wine
and drunkenness and they served
fermented wine. Whereas the biblical
symbol was
no leven in the bread and therefore if
the leven is a symbol of sin then it
must have been unfermented wine as well.
But they use fermented wine and the
round symbol and they place it in a
monstrance which has a half moon in it.
And by the way, on this particular
Catholic monstrance, you have wavy rays
of the sun and straight ones. The wavy
ones represent the female deity. The
straight ones the male deity. And this
one has the letters SFS on it. Now, in
the mysteries, you have to work out what
these letters mean. S was the sixth
letter in the Greek alphabet. F is the
sixth letter in whose alphabet?
House.
SFS
stands for 666.
You have to know their little tricks.
Here's another monstrance and there you
can see it very typically the half moon
and then when the mass is said at a high
mass then the disc is placed in there
and you have exactly the same symbol for
the deity that is used in Islam. Exactly
the same symbol. And there's another one
another monstrance for the wafer. It's
placed in there and you have Bal Hadad.
Well, there you have it, too, in ancient
Hittite culture. And there you have the
symbol of the peacocks, by the way, as
well. There you have the half moon.
There you have the face of Apollo, the
circle. And then you have the laurel
wreath, normally with 13 leaves around
it. Oh, by the way, which mighty
organization on our planet uses that
symbol?
>> United. The United Nations. That's very
interesting. U N an an
is another name for another deity, but
we'll come to that later. Here you have
Mitra,
Mitraism.
Now, Mitra is the one who kills the
bull. And uh here you have a dog helping
him. And there you have a serpent
helping him. And you have a scorpion
stinging the bull in a very strategic
place. And uh if you look at the hat of
Mitra, it looks like that. That's the
Mitraic hat. Mitraism.
Now I want you to look at that hat
carefully because in a later lecture
we'll pick it up. You'll be stunned
where we pick up the hat of Mitra. Very
interesting. The structure of the cult
was hierarchial through a series of
seven grades, each of which had a
special symbol. Cororax was the raven
under Mercury. Nymphus
was a madeup word meaning male bride.
These are the levels of mitism
under Venus, the goddess. So the priests
of Metra had to be celibate
because they were married as a male
bride to the goddess Venus. Do we have a
religious system today where the male
priests have to be celibate?
>> All right. Then we have Milles under
Mars. We have Leo under Jupiter. Paris
under Luna the moon. Hetramos under the
sun. Soul the sun. And finally we have
Patel.
That's the highest grade, the top grade
of Mitraism, father under Saturnius.
And Saturn is the god of the underworld.
Saturn is the god of death. Saturn is
the equivalent of the god Seb in the
Egyptian uh trilogy. Now, part
do we have a religious system today
where the priest is celibate? where the
deity is referred to, the one that is
the mediator is a female and where he is
called father. Do we have a system like
that today?
>> Well, you know, they say if it let me
not not be strange here. Let's just say
if it looks exactly like the old system,
then what's the possibility that it is
the old system?
>> 100%.
>> 100%. I agree with you. The Egyptian sun
god Osiris, he was worshiped by feeding
a round wafer bread exactly as they do
today. And this host is carried ritually
through the streets in Catholicism as it
was in pagan times. Balhad the system is
the system of Rome. Do you think in the
final analysis that the big religions of
the world will have a problem in
identifying with the bishop of Rome? Yes
or no?
>> No.
>> No, they won't have a problem because
under
layers of strata of hidden doctrine and
what the masses know and what the
insiders know at the very top they are
one religion and they serve the same
master. Now, I'm not going to tell you
who served the master because I could be
accused. Let's ask the Bible. What does
the Bible say? Who gave him his seat,
his power, and great authority?
Revelation chapter 13.
>> The dragon. And who's that according to
the Bible?
>> That's Satan. So, that's Luciferian
worship. That's what it is.
Here you have the symbols of sun, moon,
and star in Catholicism on all their
cathedrals. And this one is fascinating.
This is a Catholic cathedral in in
Germany as well. I was stunned. It's all
over the place. Look at this. Even in
their clocks, they know what they're
doing. They know what they're doing.
This is a modern building. Here you have
the symbol of the moon and the star. And
when the clock goes round, they have the
birth of the sun god. Balad balad balad
balhaad telling the world who the deity
is. That's why you have her over here in
the half moon with the blaze of the sun.
Straight and curled rays. There you have
the full catastrophe as well. Straight
curved in the half moon standing on the
serpent. These are ancient pagan
deities. There you have the the trinity
as well. The half moon with Mary and
child in the half moon. Same in all
these ancient paintings. And the symbol
of the bird feeding his flesh to his
young. Symbol of the fernx who rises
from the ashes and gives his life.
Six dialogues on the Lord's day. Sunday
being the l the day on which the
Gentiles solemnly adored that planet the
sun. They called it that. The Christians
thought fit to keep the same day and the
same name of it that they might not
appear causelessly peevish and by that
means hinder the conversion of the
Gentiles. This is Roman Catholic
thinking. So in other words, Sunday
worship of the day of the sun comes in.
The Bible says, "Her priests have
violated my law and have profaneed my
holy things. They have put no difference
between the holy and the profane.
Neither have they showed any difference
between unclean and clean. And they've
hid their eyes from my Sabbaths, and I'm
profaneed amongst them. We saw how Rome
shifted the Sabbath day from the
Saturday to the Sunday to bring it in
line with pagan worship. Webster's
dictionary says Sunday, so-called
because this day was anciently dedicated
to the sun or its worship, the first day
of the week. There's a reason for that.
It's because it really is the worship.
They're not deceived.
Those in high positions know exactly
what they are doing. They know it
exactly. Here's the face of the child in
the fertility symbol on a Roman Catholic
altar. And what you have around there, I
will not explain. Let's rather leave it
alone. Male, female symbol, face of
Apollo.
The Catholic world says the sun was the
foremost
what is that
symbol of heathen. Hence the church
would seem to have said keep that old
pagan name. It shall remain consecrated
sanctified and thus the pagan Sunday
dedicated to Bal to Balder became the
Christian Sunday sacred to Jesus. This
Jesus is not Jesus of Nazareth. This is
the other savior. Yave the savior. the
other god in the place, the counterfeit
savior. There you have the the sun as a
symbol over there. There you have a
symbol on a stained glass window of the
changed law. Only three on the one
tablet. There should be four. There you
have the face of Apollo on a Greek
temple. And of course, you will find it
on the Roman Catholic altar because it's
the same deity. Can you see now why this
beast has lion, Babylonian, Greek, the
leopard component, the bear component,
the feet, because the, for example, the
tiara that the pope is crowned with
comes from meersian times. There you
have it in Scandinavia. There you have
those other symbols on the walls. Let's
forget about them. And you have the
symbols of the sun all around. This is
fertility cult stuff. And this whole
issue over here is a symbol of the
victory of Lucifer
over Adonai. We'll have to go into
occultism to see that. It's really quite
scary. And uh we'll come to that.
There's another triple crown over there
supposedly representing God the Father.
So here you have the crucifix being
carried around the symbol of the death
of the one and the resurrection of the
other.
What about halos? Well, there you have a
halo in the Japanese god of happiness.
There you have a halo in Krishna. There
you have a halo in a Hindu deity. It's a
symbol of the sun. And there you have a
halo in a Roman Catholic figure. This
one I photographed in the cathedral,
brand new cathedral that they built in
London, the Roman Catholic Cathedral. It
has so many pagan symbols, it just
boggles the mind. And by the way, the
Crosia is the serpent. Can you see that
they lean upon the serpent? Very
interesting. Well, here's another uh
Eastern deity
with the halo behind it. And there are
the Japanese and Chinese ones with the
halos behind them
and the symbol of the cross. There you
have it in Mesopotamia. It was a symbol
of the sun god. This is long before
Christ. Long before Christ. There you
have it again in a Mesopotamian relief.
And there you have it. This cross in the
form of an ankh. And an ankh is a symbol
of life. The deity gives life. And the
pagan priests wore it around their
necks. So you have this line going
around coming down and very often
stretching up here. Now who wears
something like that today?
Roman Catholic priests wear it. So there
you can see the line going around the
ribbon going around is this part going
around the neck. And very often they
have the lines going up the side
symbolizing exactly the same thing. This
is a statue of Mary holding lightning in
her hand. Now, what's Mary got to do
with lightning?
Well, there's a statue of Zeus with
lightning in his hand. Because whether
you use the male form or the female
form, this deity being androgenic, it
doesn't matter. It's one in the same
deity.
Pagan symbols and hand signals. This is
the pagan symbol of the ancient trinity.
It's also shown like this. And there you
have it in Roman Catholicism.
And there you have it in the ancient
statue of Jupiter, which today is
revered as the statue of Peter, by the
way, but it comes straight out of a
pagan temple into the Vatican. And there
you have him with the ancient pagan
symbol. There you have someone kissing
his feet. And there you have the same
symbol in the um
Nordic tribes. There you have the hand
of Buddha. Exactly the same thing. Or
you have it in this form, the three
fingers.
There you have it in the papacy. There
you have the same symbol in Buddhism.
Can you see that? If they all use
exactly the same, aren't they all
exactly the same behind the scenes? Now,
let's get to a little bit more modern
cathedrals.
This symbol of the sun over there and
this triple yingyang which is the
ancient symbol of sun worship you find
in the Roman Catholic cathedral. And
this one here is phenomenal. Here is the
symbol on the floor of the cathedral in
London,
the main Catholic cathedral. It is the
ancient triple yingyang which they've
reduced now to two just reflecting good
and evil. And in the middle it makes
this structure which is the mitsto.
Have you noticed that on these animated
TV production, Kitty's games, on
television, the superheroes, Superwoman
and Super this and super that, they
carry the mitz tom, symbol of the sun
god, symbol of Lucifer, and they throw
it and go. Ninjas also use it. the mitz
tom symbol of Lucifer on the floor of a
Roman Catholic cathedral. If you're not
satisfied yet, let me take you to this
Roman Catholic cathedral. This is one
where the prominent people of the world,
I'm talking about the world leaders,
where they meet.
What's this on the door of a Roman
Catholic cathedral? Do you recognize it?
It's a yin-yang
on the door of a Roman Catholic
cathedral. And inside the cathedral,
what is this?
Black and white squares representing the
good and the evil aspects as you find it
in masonry. And what is that? The
fernics
rising out of the ashes, symbol of the
resurrection and lifegiving force of the
lightbearer Lucifer.
Very interesting.
Well, here you have um the trident.
There's another trident. Note some
trident are depicted with wavy and
straight lines. That's again union of
the male and the female. Poseidon,
Neptune, all of them had the trident. Do
you think we'll find the trident in
Roman Catholicism?
Well, we should if it's a symbol. There
you have the trident over there in a as
a symbol in Hinduism.
And there you have it in the church. In
Roman Catholic and in Anglican churches,
if you look carefully, you'll find the
trident either just blatantly or on top
of Christ or in some cases over here.
This one has the full catastrophe. He
has the pagan hand sign. He has the
pagan globe plus he has the tra tr
trident over there. Uh here you have the
flei in the ancient Assyrian cherub god.
There's the flei. They use this as a
symbol because it has a a fertility
connotation. Here's Isis with a fli.
Would you expect it in Catholicism? This
comes from paganism. Well, yes. The fli
in Catholicism in a Catholic church on a
Catholic altar. There you have the fier
coming. This is in Nunach in the
cathedral on the head of Christ and
coming out of both of his ears. Rather
sad. One can't hear very well with a
flee in each ear.
And then of course you have beads
mantras. Have you heard of mantras?
Well, Matthew chapter 6:7, when you
pray, use not vain repetition as the
heathen do for they think they shall be
heard for their much speaking. A mantra
is a repetitive prayer to put you into
an altered state of consciousness. And
that is what we have in the music today
where young people when they are
taken to certain
festivities where drugs often are
associated they also use mantras.
Mantras built into the music to place
them in an altered state of
consciousness so that another power can
take over. So mantras repetitive prayer
are a symbol of all the pagan religions.
You will find it in Islam. You will find
it in Catholicism. You'll find it in all
of them. And where does it come from?
From Babylon. There you have the pagan
priests of Bal with their mantra beads
in their hands. There you have Hindu
deities with their mantra beads in their
hands. And this of course is another
very interesting symbol. This is the eye
of Osiris.
Hatter. The eye of the god Osiris. the
oneeyed god. There you have it on the
altar of a Roman Catholic cathedral in
France. It is always the symbol of
Osiris, the symbol of the male form
Osiris or the female form, the cow hat,
the sacred cow, the female deity. She
was worshiped as in the fertility cult
as a cow giving milk, nurturing the
young or as a beautiful woman. And of
course um sadly you have that symbol
probably in your pocket right now if you
have a wallet.
So there you have the same symbol. The
triangle is sex a decimal that means it
has 60 60° mostly 666 triangle in the in
the in the mysteries the zero counts for
nothing. So if you have 360°
you have 3 + 6 + 0 you have 9. Nine is
the six upside down. Nine is one of the
highest numbers in occultism. They have
the same symbol on a uh Roman Catholic
altar. Here you have it in um
the new age movement. And when you go to
the cathedrals, you'll find it
everywhere. Symbol of Hattor or symbol
of Osiris. There it is in front of a
Jesuit cathedral on a stellar. Also you
have over here the shell symbol of the
universe. There were 360°
in the universe. There were 36 rooms. By
the way, all our systems are incrustated
with this pagan culture. If you take a
pack of cards, there are four suits.
There are four seasons. There are 52
cards. There are 52 weeks in a year
because you had this movement through
the zodiac of the planets. And this is
all depicted in card playing, in chess,
in all these games. But in any case, the
shell was a symbol of the zodiac and the
movement through the zodiac. Poseidon
was one of them. Here you have in Roman
Catholic Church you have um John the
Baptist using the Coptic shell with the
pagan symbol to baptize Jesus. By the
way, the water is in the form of the
female deity symbol. And there you have
it over the the arches of the churches.
There you have Venus born out of the
shell. And of course it is one of the
prominent symbols in the Catholic crest
in St. Peter's. Every single pagan
symbol you will find it there. There it
is in paganism. You'll find it in
Catholicism with the trinity involved.
The globe, another symbol of the pagan
deity. He is the god Mitra holding the
globe representing the universe. He is
the other deity. The biggest globe in
the world. Where will you find it? On
top of St. Peter's. By the way, that is
a rosian cross and it has those symbols
over there. And they have also a
fertility
um connotation which we don't have to
discuss in any detail. There's a globe
as well. You'll find it all over the
place. The globe symbol of Mitra. This
is Tamuz, but they say it's Jesus with
prayer beads around his neck and with a
globe in his hand. Same with this statue
over here, the globe in the hand. Sacred
heart worship, which you find in
Catholicism. There you have it in
quiztle. You'll find it through all the
pagan cultures. It comes from Babylon.
And if you go to the Vatican and you
look at the greatest
center of this type of worship, you'll
find all the pagan symbols of sun
worship right here in St. Peter's. The
sun worship, the moon worship. You have
the serpentine pillars of Bernini's
canopy. You have every aspect of pagan
worship. You even have the dome which is
known as the sun dome symbol of sun
worship. And on the floors of the
cathedrals you will find the symbols of
the zodiac. That is why stargazing,
astrology, all of these things. That was
the culture of the calaldanss.
And today you have your stargazers and
your people telling the presidents of
the world which way they should move.
The world hasn't changed at all.
Golden door, the chapel of St. Ignatius.
This is in San Francisco. There you have
the unicorn. And there you have all the
ancient ancient systems right down to
the from the fernx to the dragon to the
peacock to the ancient P and the X which
stands for 6660
plus the circle which stands for the six
or the nine. Remember the circle around
it. 360 degrees. 3 + 6 + 0 is 9. 9 is
the six upside down. So you can have
that pagan symbol on many of the altars
and it stands for 666. That's what it
stands for whether we like it or not.
You have the the staff and the miter and
the unicorn. Now let's get a little bit
closer and find out whether the pope
literally represents the ancient
deities. Here you have the eagle god
with a pine cone. That was the symbol of
fertility. Here you have the ancient
winged cherub with a pine cone which was
the symbol of his power through the
fertility cult. The biggest pine cone
and staff you'll find here, one of the
biggest at least here in Osiris worship.
This is the Egyptian deity. Osiris had
the the shepherd's rod with a pine cone
on it.
And there you have a a Hindu deity with
a pine cone in his hand. So they're all
the same. The pine cone, symbol of the
Mexican religion, pine trees, Christmas,
all those interesting things. There you
have Dionius with his staff with a pine
cone on it. A little bit of bakus with a
pine cone on it. And there's the biggest
pine cone in the world in the court of
the Vatican. There's another one in the
Vatican court with a symbol of the
female deity because Isis always walked
with two peacocks symbol of fertility in
the Vatican square and there is the
crosia the shepherd's rod of the pope
and it always has the pine cone on it.
Do you think they know what they are
doing or do you think this is pure
chance and incidental?
Well, it can no longer be chance. It can
no longer be chance. This is the staff
that the present pope uses. It's the
same one, by the way, which was used by
the previous pope.
And uh it has
this cross,
the bent cross. And it has Jesus down
there like that making the sexesimal
triangle. There's the pine cone on his
staff. And the bent cross is the symbol
of Lucifer. You'll find it in Luciferian
worship. You'll find it in Satan
worship. And you'll find it in places
where you will not expect it. What about
the pagan feasts in Christianity?
The solar symbol and the feasts of
France. You had summer solstice and
winter solstice. Those have become the
feast of St. John and the feast of the
immaculate conception where they jump
over the fire. These are Roman Catholic
festivals. They are pagan festivals.
Here you have Europe European sunish and
drude worship. Exactly the same thing.
The lighting of the fire, the circular
movement of the druds. The druds today
are alive and well and living in
Britain. Did you know that? And do you
know that druid worship? Well, let's not
get into the details. Let me leave a
little bit for later. It gets very
exciting.
The tower burning. It's the festival of
St. John and Orps that is still used
today. What about Christmas?
Well, Christmas is celebrated
everywhere. Christmas is a
representation of the serpent who gives
life to the tree Osiris who was cut down
and through the life of the serpent, the
life-giving serpent, the tree sprouts
and gives rise to a young chute. This
was decorated with round globes and
lighted up in ancient times to celebrate
the rebirth of Osiris in the form of
Horus. They would also take the log
which they called the jewel log and
throw it in the fire representing the
death and the suffering of Osiris with
his resurrection. The mistletoe symbol
of fertility and love. If you stand
under the mistletoe and get kissed,
that's it. You're in love.
Well, what was the sacrifice to the gods
on that particular day? The main
sacrifice were two unclean animals. It
was the goose and it was the pig. If you
go to Europe in Germany, the dinner for
Christmas is the Christmas goose. If you
go to England, it is the gammon. The
gammon and the goose, the two offerings.
Later, different birds were substituted.
But the pig deity is right there in with
it. Here you have uh the goddess
Amitarazzo. Saraya worship. Here you go.
Whether it's Amitarazzo or SA's
incidental here. Sa rides through the
heavens with his horsedrawn carriage.
And on the winter solstice, Sarah rides
through the heavens drawn by his
carriage. Well, depending where you were
here, you have uh Sariah being drawn
through the heavens with a horsedrawn
carriage. If you were the god Zeus, for
example, in Greece, then you were drawn
through the clouds and through the sky
on the solstice, which was the 25th of
December,
you were drawn through a by a carriage
drawn by goats. But if you lived in
Scandinavian countries where there was
snow, what do you think the animal was
that drew the sun god through the skies
on the 25th of December? Well, there you
have uh the medallion of Sibel. You have
her in a carriage and you have the sun
and the half moon with a star being born
in it. And there again you have the
Indian miniature Sarah. It's exactly the
same Sariah whether it is Sabel whether
it is the one form of the deity or the
other. If you go to the Vai in France,
Helios and his sun chariot coming out of
the water being carried away. These are
the symbols they celebrate um Elijah's
transformation as he's riding through
the sky. They make a sun deity out of
it. They take all the symbols of
Christianity and change them to pagan
symbols. Now, here's the Hittite Ron.
Can you see that? Same as in
Scandinavia. The carriage was drawn by
reindeer. Now, where does that symbol
come from? That's an interesting name,
right? Santa. Now, does that stand for
Saint or is that Santa?
Santa is something totally different.
Santa. If you rescramble that and you
take this whole system into
consideration, then you could also get
Satan. Now, who designed the little
happy man that rides through the skies
and made it available to all our
children? Well, it was Walt Disney. And
Walt Disney was a 33°ree Freemason.
Now, what is the god of the 33°ree
Freemason?
Well, we'll have to ask them what it is.
And for that, because I'm not going to
say it, I could get into trouble. Let
them say it and they can get into
trouble. Right? Come to a future lecture
and let's see who the god of the 33°ree
Freemason is. Let's have a look at the
origin of Santa Claus. Fourth century,
fourth century historical evidence shows
that St. Nicholas never existed
as a human. He was rather Christianized
version of the pagan sea god, the Greek
god Poseidon, the Roman god Neptune, the
Tutonic god Halt Nikar. Nicolations.
By the way, the Bible says in the book
of Revelations that God hates
those that adhere to the doctrines of
the Nicolations, those who served at the
throne of Nicolas.
Revelation says that. But here we have
Nicholas riding through the skies and
our children say, "Please, St. Nicholas,
bring us a present." Where's Jesus in
Christmas? It's got nothing to do with
Christmas. In the early centuries of the
Christian church, many pagan gods and
goddesses were humanized and converted
to Christian saints. When the church
created the persona s Nicholas, they
adopted Poseidon's title, the sailor.
They picked up the last name from Nika.
Various temples of Poseidon became
shrine of St. Nicholas of the
Nicolatians which God hates. This comes
from the women's encyclopedia of myths
and secrets. It's not me saying these
things.
What's the theology of Santa? Santa is
taught to most children. He's
omniresent. He can visit hundreds of
millions of homes in one night. He's
omnistant. He monitors each child. He's
allseeing, all knowing. He knows if they
were good, if they were bad. Uh he does
have great powers. He can manufacture
gifts for hundreds of millions of
children in one night. Each delivered to
the correct child. He's all good, all
judge. He judges which children have
shown good behavior and is eternal. He
never dies. What do you make of him
then?
Well, ecclesiastical history of it
attributes the introduction of the
festival of Easter
to the perpetuation of an old usage.
Just as many other customs, this is
encyclopedia predelica. So Easter is the
feast of Easter. Did you know that Pope
the Pope had the calendar shifted to
bring it in line? That's why we have the
Gregorian calendar today to bring it in
line with the pagan feast of Ishta and
forced this worship onto the Christian
world. It's paganism. We think we're
Christian, but we're not. Let's ask the
Catholic Encyclopedia. That should help.
The Easter fire is lit on top of the
mountain. This is a custom of pagan
origin. The church adopted the
observance into the Easter ceremony.
They admit it. Well, Easter, the egg,
helopus, typhon, the egg.
Where do you read about Easter bunnies
and eggs in the Bible?
I haven't seen it, but here it is.
Pre-Christian painted eggs. It comes
from paganism. It is sun worship. And
the bun with a cross on it, symbol of
tamuz. I see the woman baking cakes for
the queen of heaven. Symbol of the
goddess worship. So we have exactly the
same. The hot cross bun. Now let me just
put you straight on something. I'm not
hooked on symbols. I don't care what
symbols they use. I don't care what
flowers they use. I don't care what
symbols they use. It doesn't matter.
It's just a symbol. The fact that Satan
applies that symbol to his worship is
his business. If somebody gives me a hot
cross bun, I'll eat it. Cross or no
cross, it's just a bun.
But the fact of the matter, it is that
there is a deeper connotation. The Roman
bath England, notice the serpent symbol.
The serpent is the lifegiver. You find
it in Egypt. You find it in Hinduism.
Everywhere you find the serpent. It is
the most prominent symbol. There you
have the hydra. You find it everywhere.
Would you find it in Catholicism? Of
course. Here's a modern cathedral with a
serpent. And the main crest of the
Vatican has the dragon serpent on it.
And the dragon on the paper crest in the
Vatican museum. Vatis
means the diver. Khan is the serpent.
Vatican
means the divining serpent.
Dragon worship. That's what it is. The
Bible says the dragon gave him his seat
and power and great authority. There's
the same symbol as was used for pagan
Rome because the Vatican
has taken the seat of Caesar. It's one
and the same thing. There's the ancient
symbol of the dragon on a Roman bridge.
The Vatican has just taken it over. The
greatest serpents in the world you will
find on Bernini's canopy in Rome. It's
interesting that St. Paul's Cathedral,
which was a Protestant cathedral, has
been totally rebuilt and now has a
duplicate of St. of Benini's canopy
inside it. And on this altar, you have
the birth process taking place in Pope
Joan, the only female pope who was a
male but turned out to be a female. and
gave birth. They don't hide it. They put
it onto the altar. It's part of the
fertility right. The bee on that same
altar symbol of the pagan fertility
right just as the croser of the goddess
was a serpent.
So the croers of ceremonial
bishop's dress is also either a dragon
or a serpent as you would find it in
Egypt as covering cherub serpents
solar wheels. Now it gets exciting. I'm
almost done. Hang around. A serial
Babylonian altar with the solar wheel.
Notice there's the straight one and
there's the curved one. So you have two
crosses, one and the other. They don't
always have to be curved and straight,
but the one represents the female, the
curved one, and the other one represents
the union of the male and the female. So
you have eight spokes in this system.
This is called the solar wheel. Now
there you have the solar wheel in a
Buddhist temple. And there you have it
in Egyptian uh the Osiris riding the
solar wheel. See, it's just eight
spokes. That's really what it is is the
two crosses symbol of the sun god coming
together. There you have it in the
Catholic cathedral in Natradam and there
you have it on that famous temple at
Karanak in India where they have all
those
terrible sculptures
which are associated with that form of
worship. There's another solar wheel
with a Madonna holding it. There's a
modern one on a Roman Catholic altar.
And the biggest solar wheel in the world
you will find in the Vatican square.
There it is. Now this is an interesting
story. This solar wheel there it is.
There are eight spokes if you count them
over there. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. In the
middle you have the main symbol of the
sun god which is the circle with the
cross in it. Remember I showed you the
bull and I showed you the lion looking
towards the circle with a cross in it.
That's the symbol of sun worship. And in
the middle you have the stellar. There
it stands the symbol of Osiris
transported from Egypt to this
particular spot. And the pope had it
moved to that spot
and he commissioned or he put out a
tender to move it. and he commissioned
that those who moved it to this spot,
should they let it fall and it should
break, all the workers would be put to
death. It took a long while to find
someone who would actually do it. But
they finally did it and built it. Now,
the interesting thing about this is that
you have this huge solar wheel and you
have a wheel within a wheel. There's the
wheel within the bigger wheel. Now the
throne of God in Ezekiel is described as
a wheel within a wheel. And here the
throne of another deity is described as
a wheel within a wheel. We have today on
this planet a real live representative
of all the deities of Babylon. In other
words,
the vestments, the title Pontifax
Maximus can be traced all the way back
as it came through history and it today
subsides in the papacy. I'm not
condemning any Roman Catholic. Remember,
I'm not talking about people. I'm
talking about a system. The system
represents it. And I believe there are
many, many priests in Roman Catholicism
who serve God to the best of their
conscience and God acknowledges them as
his children. I believe that and I've
met many. But when they hear the truth,
they come out of her, my people. You
cannot serve both Bal and the other one
at the same time. You cannot serve good
and evil at the same time. You cannot
serve two masters.
So there is a choice involved. Now if we
know that this system represents not
Jesus Christ but represents the other
lightbearer whose occultic name is
Lucifer. Then we must make a decision.
And I'm telling you tonight, I believe,
in fact, I I know, am convinced, let's
put it that way,
that in the higher circles and in the
inner movings of the secret societies
within the system, they know exactly who
they are worshiping. And I will prove it
to you in future lectures. I'll put the
quotes on the screen showing who the
deity is that they worship by name.
Then we have a king of Babylon today. If
anyone bows down to him and accepts his
authority over and above the authority
of God, then you are bowing down to the
system and you become subject to the
king of Babylon.
And that is something which we as
Christians should not do because the
Bible tells us, "Come out of her, my
people, that you'd be not partakers of
her sins." I know that this is terrible
information.
But all I've done is I've shown you
paganism. I've taken you to Babylon and
I've traced it through all the religions
and you find its greatest manifestation
every single time within Catholicism
down to the rod that he carries with a
pagan incrustations on it. He knows
exactly what he's doing. They know
exactly what they're doing and where it
comes from. But it's hidden under a garb
of Christianity. And when you do that,
you call it deception. Now, I was a
Roman Catholic and when I saw these
things, when I studied Daniel chapter 7,
I was I was shattered. I got sick cuz I
was really a sincere Roman Catholic. I
got sick and I studied the scriptures
and I went to the libraries to see if
these things were so. And they were so.
I studied the history and I said, "There
must be a way out. This cannot be."
And it was so. And in the end, I had no
choice. And the more I looked, the more
I studied, the more I saw, the more I
saw that I was being duped into
believing in another God. I remember
sitting once in a Roman Catholic church.
And I was sitting there and I was
saying, "Every time I come to mass,
every time I go down on my knees, every
time I go take the wafer and I feel so
empty, please talk to me, God. Do you
exist?"
And I sat in that church and I said,
"God, if you exist, please
reveal yourself to me and show me that
you exist because I cannot understand
the ritual anymore. I cannot have a
relationship of ritual. I need a
relationship of the heart. Tell me
whether you exist."
It was the most dangerous question I
ever asked because it led me to the
Bible and it led me to show you what I
show you tonight. I don't condemn any
Roman Catholic. I was one myself. My
whole family is Roman Catholic and I
love my family and I don't want them to
be lost. I don't want anyone to be lost.
I'm not condemning. I'm revealing.
Choose thee this day whom you will
serve. Thank you. And come again to the
next lectures. Please don't miss them.
Thanks for coming.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.